hey everyone I'm Liana Galera et is
coming to you live from Comic Con with
the cast of Supergirl always such a
pleasure to welcome you guys into our
comic-con suite how's your con going so
far season one talk to me about the
evolution well I never had I know
Stephen and grants have had iterations
of they're like new iterations every
year and I was always like good and the
skirt was so iconic and so symbolic and
and like very synonymous with the comic
book version but I just you know then we
moved to Vancouver and it was cold and
it feels right it feels like the good
like the right evolution and the right
time to do it I haven't seen it like
it's cool we're going into season 5
which is a big season because you guys
are getting your hundredth episode this
year how are you feeling about that and
usually with 100 episodes they like to
do big events bring back some familiar
faces is that something that could be
happening with you guys what you did 96
Jesse's like actually I have everything
yeah Katie's we finally had Lena
discover the truth about Supergirl but
in an interesting twist she did not walk
into that party and be like you
he's never gonna give you what you think
you know she's gonna hold her her cards
close to her chest and she's gonna keep
the power so I think that's what she I
think she realizes that she hasn't had
any control of it and now she's taking
back the control and the bull is in her
court
do you think it is gonna shake up their
friendship though because fans love your
dynamic together so much yeah well
obviously things have to change
yes but it's it's the season is going to
be how that changes yeah so you have to
tune in to watch how our relationship is
going to develop and mold and and
whether it is a rocky road good bowl of
rocky road ice cream scoop a little bit
cuz you know Alex and Kelly are all
kinds of cute she's going for their
relationship next year um you know we
started off with kind of like that slow
burn but it was very intentional like
the conversations that we have with
Jessica and Robert and writers and just
being able to create something that
started a little more grounded and a
little bit more you know I think rooted
in a friendship and kind of being able
to take it amidst all this chaos they
had someone that they could lean on you
know especially when there was so much
going on with their own siblings so it
was kind of like there's there's a great
connection in that sense in and of
itself but then seeing the evolution of
it into next season and what that looks
like it's gonna be pretty awesome and
and and fine and we're taking our time
to make it respectful and classy and
graceful I love that I'm still a little
bit a little bit sexy no-kill yeah okay
seeing these two girls of course it's
gonna be and what about Brainiac and
dreamer it was really nice to see their
sparks flying we got a the l-bomb in the
finale
yeah I'm sorry they are my fav my
fingers hope you are yeah what can you
guys tease about what's coming up next
okay well basically in the aftermath of
everything that happened at the Lex
Luthor camp
Brainiac 5 is going to struggle with
being vulnerable with someone that he
loves and he's worried about getting too
close to someone because he saw that
when he was a hundred percent himself he
ended up hurting her and so it'll be fun
these next these first few episodes to
see how their relationship kind of deals
with that and how they learned to be
close with one another one of the things
I'm excited to see is James is gonna
have an eyepatch the entire season
there will be no no cure now that was
actually based on a real live injury so
like that was just for an episode thank
you I always felt like a pirate inside
you how are you feeling right now and
and what can you choose about what
you're hoping to see from James's
evolution of this next season well I
have to say it's a very gracious exit
and it's it's true to his worldview and
I really appreciate our writers for yeah
it's full it's full of integrity it's
full of it's a good decision for him and
honestly just personally just it's it's
a lot harder than I thought it would be
Excel up these guys so much and it's
gonna be tough anything for John this
season you know I'm just looking all
these ships going on here you know John
needs to get his green on at some point
[Laughter]
tinder yeah I have to say
congratulations to miss Melissa
directing your yeah it's so amazing I
know you went through the Warner
Brothers directors workshop what can you
tell us about your prep work for the
episode how you doing yeah I did I did
the orientation course and I shadowed do
you know whether you directed me the
other week it was fun I did I've done
one scene Jesse Warren are producing
director let me kind of pop in and do
one do great and it was David and a
little girl and it was special effects
it was kind of the whole gambit of every
show you see but it's cool to see how
everything's brought to life and show us
um but I just hope I just hope you know
just just by you know observing I mean
you know that she you know she picks up
she just picks things up and I'm sure
that she's not really any not really any
kind of input from me she's she's got it
already
I've even benefit those that you know
knowing the characters so well and
knowing who they are and like their
heart behind it I think we couldn't have
a better person to you know to have that
besides with David last season it was so
we're just such a being you know like
here from the get-go kind of being able
to watch you know him be able to look at
it and know exactly what to say and how
to say it or not even have to really say
anything at all you know and it'll be
the same thing for a mal I'm really
excited and proud normally David just
said do it better do it better and I do
hope you get to direct a danver sister
scene cuz I'm sure it'll I said yeah
yeah that we make a special uh
lastly guys I know you cannot say
anything about the crossover but what
have they said you can say something
okay we can say some things y'all know
Tyler
brennon brows are gonna be whoa yes
super Superman to Superman we know I
know I'll be kind of pound around with
Ruby Rose and that woman is super she'll
be great okay and I know this even just
dropped to the bomb for us that he's
playing multiple characters anybody else
playing multiple characters actually I
don't know
well I adore you all so much thank you
so much for taking time out of your baby
I got you a story guys